Trump, who has said we should it.
And you remember this.
He used to say,
I only hire the best people.
He's blaming
Chris Christie
for the hiring of the FBI
director, Christopher Wright.
Let's listen to this.
Is it a mistake to put Christopher
Wray there?
Sadly, it probably was.
You know,
he was recommended very strongly
by Chris Christie,
who was, you know, a sad case.
I mean, I watch him. He's a sad case.
Well, he's in this race.
He said just to take you down.
Well, I know.
And you know how he's doing.
He's at 1%
and he
probably won't
even make the debate stage.
Yeah.
Jason, I mean, what do you make of that?
I mean, Wray did come under attack
from many Republicans this past week.
Does this undermine
some of these claims
that they support law enforcement
when they go after Chris
Wray in that fashion?
And what about Trump
blaming this on Christie?
Well, I mean, two things down
package there.
I think
first off, I think there is
the FBI does deserve some criticism
for how they've operated.
I mean, the report came out.
But I think that the law and order folks
on the day to day
job, the FBI folks are doing a great job.
But I think the FBI still needs
there needs to be some,
you know,
I guess reconfigure nation
or addressing
the fact
that some of the cases went out too far.
I think the Democrats said this in 2016
with what they did with Hillary Clinton.
I think Republicans are saying
that legitimately now
as far as you know
Chris Christie getting blamed for hiring
Chris Wray.
That's ridiculous.
I mean
Chris Christie never had
hiring authority.
He never had the ability to say
you should be hiring this person
and if you don't,
then you're going to go down the hill.
I mean that all rests on Trump
and the other folks
in the administration.
Yeah, Mollie,
I mean, this is another case of Trump
sort of disowning people
that he's hired over the years and put in
some pretty lofty positions
Yeah, I think it's a little
bit unfair to compare
what James Comey did
to Hillary Clinton
right before the election
with that letter to what the FBI
has tried to do with Republicans.
I mean, that would Comey really was
I mean, he doesn't feel he did that,
but he really did
put his finger on the scale
there in a way that did really affect
the 2016 election.
In fact,
you know,
there's lots of reporting
that says Hillary might have won
had it not been for that letter.
So I don't know that these two things are
the same.
I would also say,
you know, Chris Wray is a Republican.
The FBI has been run almost completely,
probably completely by Republicans,
you know, since its inception.
I think that this is just a weird far
right talking point.
I don't think that
there is much mainstream
support for disbanding the FBI